There has been a ton of press around Donald
Trump's interview with George Stephanopoulos
on ABC news last week.
And I already talked a lot about the politics
in the interview, the things Trump said, the
incorrect allegations and assertions that
Donald Trump made.
But there is a 47 47 second section of this
interview, uh, that isn't getting nearly the
discussion it deserves, which exposes what
I consider to be the real Donald Trump, the
truly terrible toxic bad person that Donald
Trump is to be around.
And this is kind of buried in part three of
the interview with George Stephanopoulos.
What ABC News did, um, is divide the interview
into three parts.
The first two, I think are each about 12 or
13 minutes long.
And part three, at least as I saw it, divided
up on the ABC News, Youtube Channel is much
shorter.
And in part three, George Stephanopoulos is
pressing Donald Trump about his financial
disclosures.
And Trump is going into one of these nonsense
talking point rants that he gives, which are
never really answers.
They often contradict the thing he says in
the first 15 seconds contradicts the thing
he says in the second 15 seconds, he says
he won't release his financial disclosure,
but he hopes that eventually people see it
even though he could release it any time.
And in the midst of Donald Trump talking about
this, there's a cough in the background.
Okay.
And Trump's stops talking and the look on
his face changes.
He looks all of a sudden rabid, and he says
he wants to do it over again because this
chief of staff is coughing in the background.
Now it's actually pretty interesting that
ABC news even included this in the final cut
because Trump asked for it to be redone.
And then he does his answer with equally nonsensical
talking points.
But when you hear him talking about the cough
in the background, when you see the look on
his face, when you hear the vitriol and the
toxicity in his voice, Trump sounds like he
thinks that people around him, including his
chief of staff who cough are just worthless,
barely human forms of life.
And this is the Trump we've thought was the
real Trump from all of the reports about him
from former employees, former campaign officials,
from reports about his relationships with
his own families, uh, his own family members
and with his various mistresses and women.
He's had affairs with the audio tells us a
lot.
It's better if you're watching this so that
you also see the anger and the disgust on
Donald Trump's face.
Someone coughing.
This is a brief appearance of the real Donald
Trump, which I believe Trump didn't think
would ultimately be published as part of the
interview.
But still, if you're even willing to treat
people like this in front of George Stephanopoulos
and an entire ABC crew plus your own staff
and security, how is he behaving in more truly
private settings?
Take a look at these 47 seconds of video.
Much, much bigger, much, much better than
anybody.
Uh, thereafter my financial statement, the
Senate, they'd like to get my financial statement
at some point.
I hope they get it.
You're going to turn it over?
No.
At some point I might, but at some point I
hope they get it.
Cause it's a funnel.
It's a fantastic financial statement.
And let's do that over.
He's coughing in the middle of my answer.
Yeah.
I don't like that.
You know, you're chief of staff cough.
Please leave the room and I'll come over here.
You just can't, just to change the Sharon.
Sorry.
Okay.
Do you want to do that a little differently
then we just change the angle?
Yep.
So at some point, so at some point I look
forward to, frankly, I want, I'd like to have
people see my financial statement.
There's the literal Jekyll and Hyde transformation
that you've see on Donald Trump's face when
Mulvaney coughs trumps stops playing the character
that he's playing in the interview and he
becomes the real Trump.
And by the way, what does it even mean that
it's a financial a statement.
That's fantastic.
And if it's so good, why isn't Trump going
to publish it?
Uh, that, that's a whole other discussion
to be had.
But this is the real Trump.
He is a terrible person.
He has no empathy for anyone, period.
He's horrible to be around.
He self centered to the absolute maximum.
He could have indicated that he didn't like
the cough and he wanted to do it over by saying
sorry George, one second mic.
Are you okay and done it over again?
Any non narcissist would have behaved completely
differently here and this is one of the most
disturbing parts of the interview as Donald
sits there with pure malice in his eyes for
his own chief of staff, it was actually suggested
in this makes it even more interesting.
It was suggested that Trump was making such
a fool out of himself with his answer on this
financial disclosure issue to George Stephanopoulos.
That Mulvaney might've coughed deliberately
to ruin what Trump was saying because it was
so stupid and dumb in order to give Trump
an out.
And if that's true and we don't know if it
is, that would actually make don Donald Trump's
treatment of Mulvaney even more stunning,
even though it wouldn't surprise me that Donald
Trump's simply wouldn't be smart enough to
realize that Mulvaney was trying to help Trump
and trying to get them out of trouble.
In any case, that's the real Donald Trump.
That is the real Donald Trump, who is an absolute
disgrace and nightmare to work for.
Expose very briefly in 47 seconds of audio
and video, I encourage you to watch the entire
interview because the whole thing is a pathetic
gong show.